alors vous pour vous est-ce que c'est un
traitement miracle ou pas parler bien
dans le microcosme en miracle n'existe
pas savoir est tranquille dans les
traitements c'est pas sérieux ce qu'il
fait parce que ça donne de faux espoirs
ça va pousser les gens à essayer de
trouver de la nivaquine partout où du
plaqué nul partout et c'est un faux
espoir pour qu'un médicament soit mise
sur le marché qui soit efficace il faut
faire des études qui sont longues et des
tests sur beaucoup de personnes alors ça
ne veut rien dire je peux vous donner un
bonbon et voir que le bonbon il vous a
fait passer là encore d'un virus et je
vais dire j'ai trouvé le miracle j'ai le
bon bout ça ne veut rien dire alors il a
dit que sur 24 patients atteints du
courant d'un virus traités avec du
platine il donc cotonou de la
chloroquine c'est ce qu'on a les six
jours plus tard 75 % des patients ont
été guéris vous dites c'est peut-être un
fait de hasard n'est fait au hasard on
fait du hasard effet placé vaut il plus
fait tout ce que vous voulez on ne peut
pas dire des choses comme ça c'est c'est
même dangereux
alors moi j'ai pas l'habitude d'être
aussi sérieux mais là je dans nous avez
raison très sérieux d'accord il est
complètement fou d'annoncer des trucs
comme ça alors regardez c'est vrai ils
ont fait des essais sur de plus grand
nombre et avec des vrais scientifiques
et on voit alors c'est peut-être vrai il
était en conférence à marseille regardez
cette vidéo a fait des millions de vues
regarder ce qu'il dit on conseille nous
et d'autres depuis longtemps de donner
un antibiotique dans les infections
virales respiratoires parce qu'elle se
complique surtout de pneumopathies
l'azithromycine a montré qu'elles
étaient efficaces au laboratoire contre
un grand nombre de virus bien que ce
soit un antibiotique ça une efficacité
contre les virus et que donc tant qu'à
choisir l antibiotique ont préféré
prendre un antibiotiques est efficace si
on les virus et vous voyez que quand on
compare le pourcentage de rêve de
positif avec l'association de diderot
tri chloroquine et d'asie trop vite si
vous voyez qu'on a dit
un sport spectaculaire du nombre aux
alors paraît que ça ça a été vue des
millions de fois
il ya même des médecins qui m'ont
rappelé aujourd'hui qui m'ont dit
apparemment il y aura un remède miracle
trouvé par ce professeur à marseille je
vais être tranchant allez c'est un
charlot là vraiment c'est un charlot
on ne parlait bien dans le micro en mars
est pas faire de la méthyl comme ça
parce que il dit qu'on peut nommer
antibiotiques ça prévient les gens
connaissent pas tout ça donc ils ont en
tête il va y avoir un remède miracle
on peut prendre des antibiotiques bref
des informations qui vont dans tous les
sens on a la chance d'avoir un ministre
de la santé olivier ferrand qui est aux
piscines parce qu'il a pris la situation
en main
il ya un comité scientifique qui pilote
ça et il faut écouter ce que nous disent
ce comité scientifique
au delà de ça on peut divaguer est lassé
de la divagation
peut-être qu'il est qu'il est bon ce
traitement mais il faut le tester
on peut pas annoncer un truc comme ça et
suscité après des finalement un faux
espoir qui va déboucher sur une
catastrophe alors le lot mise de la
santé olivier ferrand est amené à réagir
à cette nouvelle
et il a dit que même s'il faut pas
s'emballer selon lui c'est très
prometteur
j'ai pris connaissance des résultats et
j'ai donné l'autorisation pour qu'un
essai plus vaste par d'autres équipes
puissent être initiées dans les plus
brefs délais sur un plus grand nombre de
patients et il ya six bêtes ndiaye la
porte parole du gouvernement elle aussi
qui a réagi regarder voudrais mettre en
garde tout le monde on se précipite pas
pour aller acheter de la chloroquine
dans les pharmacies maintenant d'abord
parce que quand on prend trop on peut
avoir des conséquences qui sont pas
terribles et ensuite parce que nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui la preuve
scientifique que cela fonctionne on a
des débuts prometteurs pour l'essai
clinique a été réalisée à marseille où
nous l'étendons parce que d'un point de
vue scientifique la discipline
scientifique veut que une expérience
pour être valide soit dupliquer
plusieurs fois avant que nous puissions
dire définitivement ça marche ou ça
demain alors il a une grosse communauté
de fans ans ce professeur raoul puisque
il ya une pétition qui a été en fait
pour écouter le professeur raoult sur
cette pétition
quatorze mille signataires voilà il
explique la france a la chance de
disposer du meilleur infectiologues au
monde
didier raoult en différant la mise en
place du protocole du professeur raoul
le gouvernement porterait la
responsabilité de l'impuissance face à
la maladie